You know what they say guys, patience is a
virtue.
The boy has no patience.
Now, this is especially true when it comes to CS:GO.
Picture this, guys: You’re lurking in a corner
when you start hearing some sound cues.
The enemy team is so eager to get to site,
they run right by you without even noticing you're there.
Every fibre of your being is screaming at
you to pull the trigger now,
but you hold your nerve for the big payoff.
That's right, guys. This week on Best of we're talking CS:GO pros holding that nerve,
and excercising that trigger discipline or at least trying to.
So let's start things off with some ice cold trigger discipline plays.
(Casting)
Now, sometimes that patience really pays off, and leaves you in the position
to get that sweet, sweet, 1,500 dollar reward. That's right guys this next section is all about the knife kills.
(Casting)
Look guys, nobody bats 1,000.
Sometimes you got all the info, all the patience and you're staring down the easiest kill of your life.
Then you whiff your spray, the guy turns on you, and you hope nobody saw that.
(Casting)
Guys, if this Best of taught you anything, it's that patience is the key to success.
Except when it comes to hitting that subscribe button, which you should do right now.
See you next week.